so when you were straight edge how old
were you about uh
uh you know and here's the thing we've
kind of gone through this before so
straight edge is like a whole like
legitimate movement and there's factions
in it and all this kind of stuff but
when you get turned on to the philosophy
yeah yeah I mean I was like between the
eight this is for me between the ages of
like probably 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
I'm in I'm in the Navy so when when were
people like smoking cigarettes or
smoking weed or whatever
let's say 12 13 14 15 16. wow that's
crazy right man uh well I don't know
they oh I've heard that before too but I
don't I don't know maybe I was in a
bubble or what but there would be people
smoking who were like 13 14 15 years old
and that was just crazy I was like for
everyone yeah they're like true that's
crazy smoking weed no kids that I knew
of really until like maybe senior year
type situation yeah that I saw anyway I
tell you what nowadays it's crazy